curr Robert Bryce is a journalist in
senior fellow at the Manhattan Institute
Center for energy policy and the
environment here in his BFA from the
University of Texas at Austin his
articles on energy and other topics have
appeared in numerous publications
including The Wall Street Journal the
New York Times National Review Atlantic
Monthly in The Sydney Morning Herald mr.
Bryce has made frequent appearances on
television and radio including CNN PBS
Fox News and NPR he's the author of
several books on energy including pipe
dreams greed ego and the death of Enron
power-hungry the myths of green energy
and the real fuels of the future and
most recently smaller faster lighter
denser cheaper how innovation keeps
proving the cat estate Astro fists wrong
please join me in welcoming mr. rice
good afternoon
I have five points to make I'm going to
make them in about 40 minutes first I'm
going to talk about scale second I'm
going to talk about coal third the big
fib finally green energy
I'm sorry fourth green energy isn't
green and finally more energy more
wealth more freedom so my first point
scale and I'm going to spend a while
talking about scale and I'm going to
start with a pop quiz who can name the
country which since 1985 has had the
biggest percentage increase in co2
emissions anyone China's a good guess
any others India it's Thailand up nearly
sup more than 600 percent another quiz
who could name the country which since
1985 is had the biggest percentage
increase in electricity generation
anyone its Vietnam up nearly 2,500
percent over the last three decades
final quiz who can name the country
which since 1985 is said the biggest
percentage increase in coal consumption
its Indonesia up nearly 6,000 percent
why do I bring up these three countries
why do I talk about these numbers
because in my view they go to the
directly to the heart of the whole
discussion we've been having over the
last decade over climate change
co2 limits co2 caps etc Vietnam Thailand
and Indonesia have a combined population
of roughly 400 million people and the
average per capita GDP in those three
countries is $3,700 that's about one
third of the world per capita GDP
average which is $13,000 and about a
ninth one ninth of the average
per-capita GDP here in the United State
which is over $53,000 why are the people
living in Thailand Vietnam and Indonesia
impoverished why are their per capita
GDP so much lower than the world average
and so much dramatically lower than what
we enjoy here in the United States I
think the answer is very simple
they live in energy poverty the average
per capita electricity consumption in
those three countries is 1,400 kilowatt
hours per year in the u.s. it's over
12,000 kilowatt hours per year put
another way the average American uses
more electricity in a single day than
the average resident of Vietnam Thailand
and Indonesia use and in an entire week
if there's one hard and fast rule in
energy economics it's this electricity
use is a reliable proxy for wealth so
two by the way is our co2 emissions per
capita co2 emissions are a also a
reliable proxy for wealth I'm talking
about these three countries because they
go to the heart of the entire discussion
we've been having over co2 emissions
remember over the past decade we've been
inundated with stories in the media with
reports from the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change we've seen the hockey
stick scandal Climategate we've had
Algor win an Academy Award and a Nobel
Prize and an Emmy we've had numerous
climate change meetings Copenhagen Bonn
Durban and there was one just a few
weeks ago in New York City and yet what
was the result of all of those meetings
effectively nothing there has been no
climate tax imposed globally we have not
had any international agreement on
climate on carbon caps I'm not here to
argue the science of co2 emissions or
climate change one way or another when
it comes to this issue
I am a resolute agnostic tell me co2 is
good tell me co2 is bad I'm
bored with the tribalism I'm bored with
the nastiness of the argument because
really what we've seen so far is really
a lot of argument about which side
you're on
are you a denier are you a catastrophist
you work for the fossil fuel industry or
do you work for Sierra Club it's all
about which side you're on instead of
going to the heart of the discussion
which is the issue of scale if you think
co2 is bad then what what's your
solution what's your answer
if you're going to go to Bangkok or
Hanoi or Jakarta what will you tell the
leaders of those countries when you
suggest that maybe it isn't a good idea
that they build a new coal-fired power
plant what's going to be your argument
tell me and do it slowly because I'm
from Oklahoma I'm a little slow this is
where the politics of green energy the
title of my presentation today becomes
so apparent numerous environmental
groups numerous university professors
and I've debated some of them continue
to claim that we can run the entire
world on renewables we don't need
hydrocarbons we don't need coal
we don't need nuclear we don't need
natural gas we can run the entire world
on renewables it's not true it's never
been true it was true 200 years ago when
those were the only options we had today
the world is a different place the
fundamental problem is the issue of
scale the fundamental issue is the
tyranny of big numbers over the last
decade alone global energy consumption
has increased 28 percent the increase
alone has been 56 million barrels of oil
equivalent per day that's an increase of
about 7 saudi arabia's of oil output in
the last decade alone I normalized my
energy units around oil why because the
public understands oil better than any
other energy commodity how many of you
of you here under
and what a British thermal unit is go
ahead and raise your hands what about a
Joule
what about exajoules what about million
tons of oil equivalent what about
thousand cubic feet of natural gas we
measure energy units in a lot of
different ways but the public
understands effectively none of them but
for oil since the 70s the Saudis have
been producing roughly 8.3 million
barrels of oil per day so I like to use
Saudi Arabia units today globally we're
using 256 million barrels of oil
equivalent per day that's one and a half
exit joules I like exajoules I like that
like how it sounds
31 Saudi Arabia is 256 million barrels
of oil equivalent per day and of that of
that 31 Saudi Arabia's we get 27 of them
from coal oil and natural gas we
conserve consume every day 10 Saudi
Arabia is in the form of oil 9 in the
form of coal 7 from natural gas to from
hydro 1 and 1/2 from nuclear and 1 I'm
sorry and point 7 Saudi Arabia's from
all the political darlings of the moment
solar wind geothermal and biomass so we
can talk about co2 emissions being bad
we can say they're good again I'm bored
with the argument my question is if you
think co2 is bad where will we find that
replacement those 26 or 27 saudi
arabia's of carbon free energy that we
can deliver every day that's today to
the people who are living in the world
I'm not even talking about population
growth that is do to come in the next
few decades where will we find those
extra Saudi Arabia's of carbon free
energy to bring the people in the
developing world out of the dark and
into the modern world from where will it
come that's the challenge that we face
that is the scale challenge scale scale
scale it's a theme of my new book by the
way I'm pleased to have you mentioned at
the intro smaller faster lighter denser
cheaper
how innovation keeps proving the
catastrophes wrong tell your friends
tell your neighbors you don't have to
read it you just have to buy it I've
written five books collect all of them
they make great gifts and if you buy
down your Kindle I make a better royalty
okay end of commercial I have two
children in college so I have to do that
end of the commercial back to the issue
of scale over the last decade alone
global energy consumption rose by 28
percent global co2 emissions rose by 29
percent in the decade in which this was
the environmental issue that dominated
the news dominated all of the thinking
all of the rhetoric from the
environmental groups co2 emissions rose
by 29 percent why because of Thailand
Vietnam Indonesia South Korea Malaysia
Afghanistan Cambodia Laos China India
all of these countries that are trying
to improve that and grow their economies
and they're doing so in the same fashion
that we in America did they're doing so
with the help of hydrocarbons and more
particularly with the help of coal co2
emissions in the last decade in the
Middle East are up 58% in Asia of 74
percent in Africa up 30 percent in
Europe down about 4% in Australia down
about 1% and remarkably in the u.s. down
six and a half percent the u.s. again
you won't hear this from Greenpeace
Sierra Club Natural Resources Defense
Council etc by the way they don't like
me and you know that's okay you can't be
friends with everyone and if you were
what fun would that be the u.s. is
leading the world in reducing its co2
emissions why because we have an
abundance of natural gas and over the
last few years we've seen natural gas
displacing coal in huge quantities we
repeatedly hear from the leaders of the
environmental movement the climate
change activists Bill McKibben among
them from 350.org
saying the US should model itself on
Germany okay
look at the scale numbers since 2005 the
US has reduced its co2 emissions more
than any other country in the world
we've reduced our co2 emissions by about
400 million tons without a national
policy aimed at doing so meanwhile
Germany has instituted the energy venda
a nationwide program that has now been
subsidized to the tune of about 100
billion dollars in the last five years
industrial electricity rates in Germany
are up 60% industrial users in Germany
have said that they have to see relief
from high energy prices unless gern and
if they do not Germany in the words of
Germany's industry minister says the
country risks dramatic
deindustrialization Germany is held up
by the environmentalists as the model
we're supposed to follow and yet in the
last five years in the absence of a
state of national policy the u.s. was
reduce its co2 emissions more than any
other country in the world and in fact
has reduced its co2 emissions six times
more than what has occurred in Germany
over that same time period the u.s. is
leading the world in reducing co2
emissions and showing the rest of the
world how to do it
the final point on scale is this the
hard reality is that hydrocarbons for
countries all over the world rich and
poor alike provide the path to wealth
and better economies coal my second
point we're inundated with stories about
the shale Gale and shale oil and the
rise of those commodities here in the
United States and rightly so it has been
a remarkable turnaround in America's
energy fortunes and I'll talk about that
more in just a moment but the politics
around grain energy and the media that
covers the energy market and by this I
mean the mainstream media they are
fixated on solar and wind and batteries
and geothermal and biofuels and so on we
don't talk about we don't hear much
about the boom in the world's biggest
electricity the the fuel that provides
more electricity than any other and that
is coal since 1973 no other form of
energy has grown as fast as coal why
because the world wants electricity no
other form of energy is as versatile or
as powerful as electricity the
essentiality of electricity to modernity
is in controvert able I don't use
PowerPoint if I was going to show if I
were to show you one slide today I
choose a slide that appeared in my my
fourth book power-hungry it's the top 20
countries ranked by GDP in the top 20
countries ranked by electricity
generation the correlation is almost 1
to 1 the countries that can produce
cheap abundant reliable flows of
electricity electricity that we take for
granted here in the in the United States
the countries that can produce abundant
electricity are the ones that prosper
and the ones that can't produce cheap
abundant reliable electricity are the
ones that are poor
full-stop period end of story Elvis has
left the building
there is nothing else left to say Africa
is the Dark Continent why because it's
dark 1.1 billion Africans use about the
same amount of electricity as 35 million
Canadians and so what are the countries
in the developing world doing they are
turning to coal in a big way why is coal
consumption booming because it's perfect
for electricity generation I mentioned
that here in the US we've been able to
substitute natural gas for coal and in
doing so reduce our co2 emissions that
is not a possibility in Thailand in
Vietnam in Indonesia in China in India
they don't have the natural gas
infrastructure that exists here in the
United States we had it we could move
those we could switch fuels here in the
United States they don't have that
option
why is coal consumption booming because
resources of coal are geographically
widespread the fuel is cheap and the
price is not affected by any OPEC
like entity last December the
International Energy Agency in Paris
made a remarkable prediction they
estimated that by 2018 or so global coal
consumption will exceed global oil
consumption this is an amazing
projection and this is from the
International Energy Agency which has
been promoting renewables and renewable
technology as much as any international
entity that I know of in their December
report they last December they said coal
demand knows only one direction up and
by 2018 they're predicting that that
coal consumption will exceed oil
consumption this is a stunning
projection the last time coal
consumption exceeded oil consumption in
the United States was 1949 I recently
completed a paper for the Manhattan
Institute it was published just a couple
of weeks ago the key finding from the
paper in addition to showing that coal
has been growing at such a rapid clip
was this between 1990 and 2010 globally
about 1.7 billion people gained access
to electricity of that number about 830
million
gained access due to coal-fired
electricity put another way for every
one person who gained access due to
solar and wind for gained access due to
hydro six gained access due to natural
gas and 13 gained access thanks to coal
I'm adamantly Pro you clear I am
adamantly Pro natural gas but we cannot
deny the energy story of the moment so
what should the policy then be for the
United States going forward well it is
not the policy that is being pursued by
the Obama administration the Obama
administration has effectively said they
will not support financially any Coal
Fired project anywhere in the world
unless it uses carbon capture and
sequestration well the number of power
plants globally who are now using
coal-fired are now using carbon capture
and sequestration I could count on one
hand the project that the process is
extremely expensive and
is not suitable in very many places and
yet this is the stipulation that they
have imposed in my view it's absolutely
wrong headed what should we be Purdue
proposing using our export credit
agencies the Export Import Bank the
overseas Private Investment Corporation
World Bank we should be promoting the
most efficient generation technologies
supercritical combustion ultra
supercritical combustion so that we
wring more electricity out of each
kilogram of coal that we consume that is
a sensible policy to effectively say no
coal to the developing world is simply
wrong this takes me to the big fib and
this is where the politics excuse me the
politics of green energy become even
more obvious what is the big fib I
alluded to this earlier it is the
repeated claim by environmental groups
and leading environmentalists that we
can run the world on renewables
Greenpeace claims renewable energy quote
smartly used can and will meet our
demands no oil spills no climate change
no radiation danger no nuclear waste the
Sierra Club has a campaign called beyond
coal another call beyond oil and another
beyond natural gas by the way there
beyond coal campaign is being funded
largely with a 50 million dollar grant
from former New York Mayor Michael
Bloomberg three fifty.org which was one
of the key organizers of the big climate
March in New York City in September that
attracted some three hundred thousand
people has a campaign called fossil free
and it's aiming to convince universities
colleges and other entities that have
large pensions pension funds and
inventin endowments to divest themselves
of any ownership in in hydrocarbon
production they are welcome to push that
agenda and they are getting some
traction with it but again the reality
is that renewables cannot even keep pace
with the growth in global energy demand
much less displaced significant
quantities of hydrocarbons
is not an opinion it is an easily
provable fact 350.org has pushed this
there one of their slogans which is do
the math okay let's do the math and I
promise you it's simple since 1985
global electricity demand and I'm just
going to focus on electricity I'm going
to forget about oil even though oil is
irreplaceable in transportation and now
provides about 33 or 34 percent of all
global energy is going to ignore oil
just look at electricity since 1985
global electricity demand has been
growing by roughly 450 terawatt-hours
per year that's 450 trillion watt hours
we've added about one brazil's worth of
new electricity demand every year for
the last three decades and the
projections from BP Exxon Mobil the IEA
the EIA are all in pretty uniform
agreement that we will be adding about
one new Brazil of demand every year
through 2030 or 2040 so that the
objective here is one new Brazil per
year of generation 450 terawatt-hours is
the increment that we have to meet so
let's look at wind one of the darlings
of the environmental movement what would
it require then if we were just to use
wind to meet that 450 terawatt-hours of
new demand I'm not talking about
displacing significant demand just
looking forward at future demand growth
what would it take to produce at 450
terawatt-hours of electricity with wind
well it would require installing roughly
240 thousand megawatts of new wind
energy capacity every year the power
density of wind energy is 1 watt per
square meter what's power density the
basic metric and physics power density
is a metric is a measure of energy flow
that can be harnessed in a given area
volume or mass the power density of wind
energy and I show it in smaller faster
lighter denser cheaper is 1 watt per
square meter we need 240,000 megawatts
240 billion watts and 1 watt per square
meter that's 200
40 billion square meters that's 240,000
square kilometers roughly 93 thousand
square miles every year just to keep
pace with electricity demand growth by
using wind would require us to cover a
land area the size of the state of
Minnesota with nothing but wind turbines
that's a land area the size of the
United Kingdom every year just to meet
incremental demand growth the math here
is elementary school simple let me make
it even simpler for you but take it down
to a daily rate of installation of wind
turbines on a daily rate we would have
to cover a land area of about 660 square
kilometers or roughly 11 Manhattan
islands every day with wind turbines
just to meet incremental demand growth
this is not going to happen ladies and
gentlemen I'm sorry I
you know I'm hopeful I believe in
technology I don't believe in miracles
what about solar I'm bullish on solar
and for the record I'm opposed to all
energy subsidies unless I'm getting them
I have 3200 watts of solar panels on the
roof of my house in Austin Texas why
because the City of Austin paid 2/3 of
the cost 1 am i stupid sure I'll take
the subsidy my neighbors come by and say
like your solar panels I say thank you
you paid for them takes a little shine
off of them it seems I'm bullish on
solar Solar is coming down in price
dramatically and if we can't win solar
solar energy production with even
moderate amounts of battery storage
that's a big deal particularly for
people in island economies and rural
economies but let's go back again to the
issue of scale what would it require to
meet that 450 terawatt-hours of new
electricity generation every year with
solar we can look at Germany and figure
it out very quickly Germany has more
installed solar capacity than any other
country roughly 36 gigawatts 36,000
megawatts last year all of that capacity
produced 30 terawatt-hours of
tricity we need 450 terawatt-hours
simple math 450 divided by 30 we would
need 15 times as much solar capacity as
now exists in Germany and we'd have to
install it every year just to meet
incremental demand let me give you one
more set of numbers and it's on us coal
versus us solar if you think coal
consumption and coal generation in the
United States is dead
think again last year coal consumption
in the United States rose by five
percent now I've just told you that coal
consumption the u.s. is falling and it
has but remember in the last 18 months
or so 24 months natural gas prices have
risen and so utilities have taken the
rational economic move and said well
we'll burn coal because now we can coals
a little cheaper for us so we'll burn a
little more coal and they are burning a
little more cold 5% increase in 2013
that percentage increases minuscule
compared to the growth that occurred in
solar last year here in the United
States up 114 percent that's huge growth
but let's look at the absolute numbers
the increase in coal use in the United
States last year was 380 thousand
barrels of oil equivalent per day that 5
percent increase amounts to 380 thousand
barrels of oil equivalent per day all of
the solar projects in the United States
including my solar panels on the roof of
my house produce the equivalent of 42
thousand barrels of oil last year in the
United States last year just the
increase in coal consumption is equal to
9 times the contribution of every solar
project in the United States these are
the facts and if you don't believe me
you can look at the BP statistical
review and do your own calculations but
this is the issue these are the facts
that have to be brought forward over and
over and over and over again because the
politics of green energy the romanticism
about green energy is so incredibly
strong
why am i frequently asked why is that
and I talk about it in my new book but
it is this romanticism that and in fact
this idea that is very deep inside of us
and it's a myth that we have bitten from
the Apple of knowledge we have sinned
because we have too much technology it
goes back to the book of Genesis and
Adam and Eve and we see it in John
Jacques Rousseau and the idea of the
noble savage through Henry David Thoreau
in Walden where he said cultivate
poverty like a garden herb from Genesis
to Rousseau to Thoreau to Rachel Carson
Edward Abbey and today Bill McKibben and
Naomi Klein the idea is we have to go
back to nature we have to we're we have
sinned we have too much technology we're
doing too much traveling too much using
too much and because of that we have
sinned and repentance means going back
to nature
to something like 40 acres and a mule
ladies and gentlemen I ain't going back
not willingly my fourth point green
energy isn't green the environmental
ideal can be summed up very succinctly
and that is small is beautiful it was a
title of a book that was published in
the 70s by EF Schumacher small is
beautiful small footprints are the
environmental ideal we don't want farms
stretching over all of Michigan we want
land that can we can use for hunting
that we can just enjoy looking at that
we can have homes on that we can do you
know have baseball diamonds and football
fields small is beautiful small
footprints are the environmental ideal
but one of the major problems that we
face now with green energy and by this
I'm talking in particular and more
specifically rather about wind and
biofuels I've just told you what energy
sprawl will come with wind energy I did
a simple calculation in my book which
showed if we wanted to replace
coal-fired electricity with wind energy
here in the United States just
coal-fired electricity
we would have to cover a land area
roughly the size of Italy 300,000 square
kilometers where do we have that much
vacant land we don't have that much
vacant land and if you look at what the
backlash has been to the wind energy
both here in the United States in
Ontario Canada in the United Kingdom in
Australia in New Zealand the backlash
has been tremendous why because people
who live in rural settings like this
don't want to look out their windows and
go out there they're there on their
porches all night or every night and all
night have to look at red blinking
lights on 400 foot high turbines that
are just a few hundred yards or even a
few miles away from their homes they
don't want energy sprawl they don't want
to look at this kind of what I view is
an environmental eyesore and yet this is
the thank you it's a battle that's
happening here in Michigan on your Lakes
here in this state I mentioned we would
have to set aside a land area the size
of Italy just to replace coal-fired
electricity you want to read a story
about someone who has seen the brunt
taken the brunt of the energy sprawl
that's been created by the wind energy
business Google a guy named Dave ends
Enz is his last name it'll take you to
my website there's a statement from Dave
ends and I asked him for it and I
published it he and his wife raised nine
children on 40 acres outside of Denmark
Wisconsin he spent his career as a
millwright in Green Bay and I checked
his property records I checked
everything about this guy and it all
worked out he and his wife are now
living in an RV
why because the wind energy business
built about six turbines within about
half a mile of their home and the noise
was so much they can't sleep at night
they had to abandon their home and their
story has been repeated over and over
and over not just here in the United
States but all over the world and yet
the what we're being told by the
environmental left is this lie that wind
energy is Green wind energy is the
opposite of green wind energy is the
opposite of green because of energy
sprawl it requires too much land
now what about biofuels I've been a
longtime critic of the biofuel scam more
specifically the corn ethanol scam this
is one of the longest running robberies
of American taxpayers in this country's
history we are now burning roughly 40%
of the corn produced in this country to
produce infinitesimally small amounts of
gasoline replacement this has never been
an energy program it has always been a
farm subsidy program in an article
published last year in strategic studies
quarterly and a journal that is the US
Air Force's most prestigious journal the
author Ike Keefer found that merely to
replace US oil needs for transportation
with biofuels would require planning and
land area of about 700 million acres
with corn he went on he said this is 37%
of the total area of the continental
United States this is madness this is
the kind of madness that meets stupid
come in the other direction we're
burning food to make motor fuel and the
amount of land that would be required to
scale up this biofuel production to make
meaningful reductions in our our
consumption of hydrocarbons is not just
absurd it's cartoonish green energy and
by this I'm talking about wind and
biofuels is not green my final point
more energy more wealth more freedom and
I'm a calm down here I'm getting all
going all Joel Osteen on you here the
essentiality of electricity to modernity
is incontrovertible the world wants
electricity the world demands more
electricity the International Energy
says of electricity it is crucial to
human development it says the
availability of electricity is one of
the most clear and undistorted
indications of a country's energy
poverty
status this takes me back directly to
the issues that I mentioned before with
scale and coal and it takes me back to
Indonesia
Indonesia's coal consumption has grown
faster than that of any other country in
the world over the last three decades
between 1990 and 2010 about 100 million
Indonesians gained access to electricity
over that same time period
Indonesia's per capita GDP rose by 442
percent
life expectancy increased by 8 years
infant mortality fell by 45 percent
child malnutrition fell by 65 percent
illiteracy declined by 77 percent this
is not a coincidence more energy means
more wealth more electricity in
particular means more wealth let's look
at Pakistan
the country where the US has been
involved now for decades and we continue
to use drone strikes and and and and in
that country which has been riven by
conflict now for decades and let me make
a quick comparison between Pakistan and
Texas the state where I live the two are
about the same size roughly 700,000
square kilometers
Pakistan is a 193 million people and
only 24,000 megawatts of electricity
generation capacity in Texas there are
26 million people and 110,000 megawatts
of electricity generation capacity Texas
has one seventh of Pakistan's population
and four times as much generation
capacity that translates directly into
wealth the GDP of Texas is roughly 1.4
trillion
Pakistan is one has 1/10 of that GDP
about 140 billion therefore there is no
surprise that Pakistan is doing what
building coal-fired power plants at
least 15 gigawatts I mentioned Africa
earlier Africa uses about with 1.1
billion people uses about the same
amount of electricity as
thirty-five million Canadians the GDP of
Africa with 1.1 billion people is
roughly 2.3 trillion dollars Canada's
GDP is nearly as large at 1.8 trillion
Africa has 30 times as many people as
Canada and yet its GDP is nearly I'm
against 30 times as many people as
Canada and yet Canada's GDP is nearly as
large as that of all of Africa
let's move beyond electricity and talk
just about natural gas very briefly and
talk about what's happening today
let's look at Ukraine and Russia last
April Gazprom Russia's gas utility or
gas monopoly rather announced it was
raising prices on gas deliveries to
Ukraine the new price $11 per million
btu's $11 per Giga Joule the posted
price today for natural gas in the
United States is roughly four and a half
dollars people of Ukraine are going to
be paying more than twice as much for
their natural gas as we pay here in the
United States the per capita GDP in
Ukraine is less than $4,000 per year in
Panama and Panama it's twice that in
Poland it's three times that in Russia
it's more than three times that as I
mentioned here in the US it's 53,000
dollars more than ten times as much
Ukraine is one of the poorest members of
the old Soviet bloc and yet now what is
happening Putin and his band of
kleptocrats in the Kremlin are going to
squeeze him even harder meanwhile
Germany has hitched its wagon to
Vladimir Putin and his band of
kleptocrats at the same time that they
are imposing these renewable mandates
and higher energy costs throughout their
economy Europe needs more energy more
specifically it needs cheaper energy and
instead what is it going to get more
expensive energy that is not as reliable
as what we have here in the United
States more energy more wealth more
freedom the point is obvious using
hydrocarbons allowed us humans to escape
the the whim of the
of nature it allowed us to escape the
vagaries of the Sun and the wind and the
rain more energy has allowed us to move
and travel more freely than ever before
we are prospering today like never
before why because we are using more
energy than we ever have in 1950 about
half of the adults on the planet were
literate today that figure is about
ninety percent a century ago few women
on the planet could vote today with a
few notable exceptions including Saudi
Arabia and other Islamic countries women
are voting in nearly every country in
the world and they are taking leadership
roles in politics and well they should
in 2012 at the Olympic Games in London
for the first time women were competing
on every team in the Olympics today
people are living longer healthier freer
lives than at any time in human history
we are living at one of the most
peaceful times in all of human history
and why is that I believe it is directly
due to our use of increased energy
better education increased mobility more
travel more commerce more connectivity
all of these things are allowing more
people to connect with other people all
over the world and by doing commerce
they're building relationships and in
building relationships they are reducing
conflict now let me conclude over the
past few years we have been inundated by
claims that we're using too much energy
in fact Bill McKibben the leader of
three fifty.org and one of the stars of
the climate March in New York City a few
weeks ago has published a statement
saying we should be reducing our hydro
carbon consumption globally 20 fold we
are facing a very entrenched and an
influential group of people who believe
we should be using not just less energy
dramatically less energy this is exactly
the wrong place to go we should be
focusing on providing more people to
more energy to more people all over the
world
this point was made in an essay it was
published in August in the New Republic
by a Martius Sen a Nobel prize-winning
economist who's from India he wrote
quote in thinking about expanding human
freedom today and sustaining it in the
future we have to take note we have to
take fuller note of the need for greater
energy use for a large number of
deprived people in the world he
continued saying the focus has to be
shifted from a single-minded
concentration on reducing emissions to a
broader understanding of the range of
needs of people and the demands that
come from expanding and sustaining their
substantive freedoms to live reasonably
good lives that's it exactly
that is it exactly we have to move
beyond this narrow-minded focus on
emissions only and look at how people
are living their lives globally and look
at them with a cold eye we have 1.2
billion people around the world today
who are living without electricity in
Pakistan alone that number is 60 million
people in Pakistan alone the population
living without electricity is greater
than the combined populations of New
York Pennsylvania and Florida combined
we have to move beyond this narrow focus
on reduced emissions and this narrow
focus on green energy we have to move on
and look at the and realize and
recognize an honor a fundamental truth
which is that more energy means more
freedom for people all over the world
climate change activists are welcome to
say that climate change is urgent and
that we have to begin using less energy
and we have to do that now they are
welcome to say that but in doing so they
are arguing for more poverty I'm opposed
to poverty I'm for more energy more
wealth and more freedom and I think you
should be as well thank you
thank you
we have time for some questions if you
raise your hand and please stand when
the microphone gets to you if you want
the mic to come to you please also raise
your hand and we encourage students to
ask questions as well I actually have
two questions if that would be okay
surefire way all right
my first question pertains to Germany
hitching on to Russia if you could like
talk and detail a little bit about that
that would be awesome and my second
question is whether you think that the
potential energy has the potential to
alleviate the growing uh entered energy
consumption worldwide particularly
thorium reactors it's sure comment on
that sure of course we take your last
nuclear question first
I'm Pro nuclear adamantly so my
colleague Mark Mills is going to speak
tonight and he's been a nuclear advocate
for decades but we have to be clear-eyed
when it comes to nuclear and I became
very clear-eyed after visiting Japan in
September the Japanese nuclear sector in
the wake of Fukushima is in crisis total
crisis and it's not clear if and when it
will emerge from crisis if nuclear
energy can't work in Japan I don't know
if it can work anywhere on the scale
that is needed what we've seen in the
last few years has actually been I think
quite heartening and to see some members
of the environmental left embracing
nuclear energy but in my view they've
been a too glib by at least half you
know there's a I'm simplifying but
there's kind of this attitude of well
I'm green and they're I believe in
nuclear therefore I'm more virtuous than
those anti-nuclear greens well okay
that's fine but nuclear is problematic
and the first problem is it is
incredibly expensive it's way too
expensive there are five reactors being
built right now in the United States one
of them is the Watts bar number two that
reactor started construction in 1973 in
1988 they put down their tools and
walked away Bechtel is now finishing a
4.2 billion dollar contract that hopes
to finish that reactor by the end of
next year from start to finish Watts bar
reactor will take 42 years
to construct I don't know what the
capital costs ultimately will be I would
guess it would probably be on the order
of $10,000 per kilowatt you can install
new gas fired capacity in the United
States for a thousand dollars a kilowatt
it's incredibly expensive the only
reason those other four reactors there
are to being built in Georgia and to in
South Carolina the only reason they're
being built today with natural gas
prices at $4 and the nuclear industry
has said they need natural gas prices at
$8 for nuclear to be competitive across
the country the only reason those four
reactors are being built is because the
public utility Commission's in Georgia
and South Carolina are allowing cost
recovery ahead of time if we're going to
be serious about reducing co2 and I've
said this many times I'm in favor in 2n
natural gas to nuclear those are the
those are the fuels that are can scale
our lower carbon and and and and it
makes sense but nuclear right now is
just simply too expensive that's the key
stumbling block you asked specifically
about thorium thorium works and the
Indians have been have been working on
it for decades but all of all the
reactors today we have our uranium
fueled and that's because uranium has
been first to market its dominant in the
marketplace and it works thorium has the
advantage of producing less fissile
material as at the back end and that's
great but there's no demand for it
particularly when uranium we have a
supply chain now built around uranium
Russia and Germany your question was
about natural gas supply was that yeah
well German that Germany has effectively
said we'll look we're just going to rely
on the Russians for our natural gas they
and and because the Russians have built
and are building pipelines into Germany
and the Germans have said effectively
well that's ok with us and so Germany
has cast its lot with Russia on
geopolitical reasons you know geography
is destiny a lot of political scientists
say that in in that case I think that's
what they've just simply decided yes sir
just in case there's anybody in this
room who doesn't know these statistics
would you speak to the number and kind
of birds being killed by windmills per
year thank you I didn't pay you this
answer to ask that question but I might
well have
this is an issue that to use a little
birding bird tacks on sticks in my craw
I've been reporting on the migratory
bird treaty act and eagle Protection Act
for more than 20 years and seen the US
government pursue and prosecute oil and
gas industry multiple times the electric
utility industry multiple times in the
late 1980s in a multi-jurisdictional
task force the Fish and Wildlife Service
and local law enforcement agencies
wildlife enforcement agencies went after
the oil and gas industry in Oklahoma
Texas Louisiana and New Mexico and
brought hundreds of cases for violations
of the migratory bird treaty act and
well they should have these companies
were operating open pits that were
trapping birds and killing them on the
order of five hundred thousand birds per
year that was the estimate at that time
today the Fish and Wildlife Services own
biologists estimate similar magnitude of
bird kills due to wind turbines and
there has been exactly one prosecution
of the wind industry for violating the
migratory bird treaty act and the eagle
Protection Act we have a pernicious
double standard when it comes to
wildlife law enforcement in this country
and the wind industry has effectively
been given a blank check oh yeah sure go
ahead and violate the law and they've
append that and the Obama administration
recently gave a permit for a massive
wind project in Wyoming hasn't been
built yet but in the Bureau of Land
managements own data they predict dozens
of Golden Eagle kills every year at this
one wind energy project the incumbent
energy sectors would never be able allow
would never be allowed to do that never
be allowed to violate the law in the
magnitude that the wind industry is
already getting approval for I find it
just incredible if we have the law
enforce the law but if you're not going
to enforce the law repeal the law
because we can't have a double standard
justice is supposed to be blind but in
this case green energy is getting a
getting a get-out-of-jail-free card and
I think it's a it's it's atrocious
thank you sir if the reason that we're
having this discussion in the first
place is that people think that going to
that global warming will plunge us into
a environmental disaster far worse than
the disaster of everyone trying to
reduce their their fuel consumption
because you speak a little bit too about
that that theory and what the trade-off
might be being that it's like impetus of
this this problem in the first place and
also is the high price of a nuclear
reactor a natural high price or is it a
high price that has only brought about
by over-regulation and a rage Asst
environmental concerns let me make sure
your first question I'm sorry I'm a
little fuzzy on okay
be my dad right okay well I guess here's
the way I'd answer your first question
which is this which is okay let's assume
that we are changing the climate and
changing it for the worse and that we're
going to see our climate getting hotter
or a more extreme events that we're
going to have harsher winters and more
extreme summers well what is that going
to mean we're going to need a lot more
energy we're going to need a heck of a
lot more energy because we're going to
have to stay warm in the winter and
we're going to have to stay cool in the
summer we're going to have to have more
desalination plants to provide the fresh
water because we may be exhausting our
freshwater resources if that and K in
fact we're going to be facing more
drought which is one of the claims that
we've heard from you know some climate
scientists so this is the part where I
say you know I'm an agnostic tell me co2
is good tell me it's bad here what you
know it's obvious to me that regardless
of what the climate does whether we're
facing significant changes in climate
we're going to need a lot more energy
well where's it going to come from it's
not going to be coming from solar and
wind will those those sources will grow
dramatically but we're going to exploit
the cheapest energy for
first always have always will
your second question is why the price of
nuclear is so high well one of the
reasons is that we've been building
reactors that are best spoke we've been
Taylor making reactors I went to France
and when I was working on my last on
power hungry a few years ago and it was
a French engineer who reminded me that
at Three Mile Island the control centers
for there were two reactors there one
was built what by one company and the
other was built by a different company
in France all the reactors are the same
model they can interchange all their
engineers they you know they have one
design and they said this is our design
but now we're building reactors that are
large they're complex they require
passive safety and as you you know they
work they are in the new ones are going
to have passive safety systems passive
cooling systems but you're right that
the regulatory regime is in fact so
strict that it is forcing costs up and
in fact a friend of mine who went to
Hillsdale Bruce Hamilton and I he's been
in the nuclear sector for many years he
said the problem of the nuclear sectors
were making reactors too safe well
that's a controversial statement I said
well well Bruce slow down here and he
said well look what the regulations have
gotten so extreme to we've gotten this
this degree of safety factor that is so
so small though the potential for you
know catastrophic of it is so small
we've engineered the price way up what
we need is passive safe reactors that
can be mass-produced but I don't see
that happening not in anything like the
near term the company to bet on when it
comes to nuclear in the United States
right now is new scale in us see a
Elliott oregon-based company they're
planning a new small modular reactor
with about a hundred and twenty-five
megawatts electric output and I they're
claiming that it's going to be similar
in cost to standard nuclear reactors six
thousand dollars a kill a lot of
capacity something like that but I ran
into these guys in Idaho Falls in August
I said well blue sky for me tell me what
your best guess is for when you're going
to make this all happen when you're
going to start generating electricity
from your reactor
and this is cognizant of the fact that
they have the land they're going to put
it at Idaho National Lab federal land in
Idaho they have a customer they've
gotten do a backing for I think they got
a grant and alone if I'm not mistaken I
said so blue sky for me when when will
you deploy it 2022 it's gonna take you
eight years a lot of that's the
regulatory regime any others yes sir
I got a question it might have been
addressed in your book and if it has
been addressed in your book you can just
tell me to sit down and buy your book
don't have to read it you just have to
buy it that's right I'm connected to
electrical power generation and one of
the things that is bothering the
electrical business the generation
business is the last doubling of the
gross national product in this country
was only accompanied by a 20% increase
in energy consumption and is there a
point in the evolution of a
post-industrial nation like us where
your basic elector power consumption
within the economy becomes fixed and you
don't have to depend on incremental
increases in energy to achieve economic
growth that's a great question and it's
one that is really fascinating on a lot
of different levels and I'm sure my
friend Peter Grossman can talk about it
at length let me just mention one
economist in 1865 William Stanley Jevons
one of the great economists in world
history wrote a book called the coal
question and he came up with what was
called the Jevons paradox and briefly he
said that in brief he said energy
efficiency doesn't reduce energy demand
it increases it well that's held true
now for decades and it's held true here
in the United States where we've gotten
more efficient lights and more efficient
computers things and so we buy more of
them you know we have more efficient
cars but we buy more of them more
efficient computers but we're also at
the point now in the US where we may be
proving Jevons wrong in that we've read
just a level of wealth where we don't
need more energy we don't need you know
we've got a you know it's fashionable to
drive a Prius fashionable to have
smaller homes
we're sated we can't use more energy
we've got as much as we can use and
we're happy with all of it it's not true
in Pakistan India China other developing
countries but your point is right on in
terms of one of the most important
debates now in the energy economics
field the peak Verdun gasoline demand in
the United States was 2005 in Japan
refined product demand is falling by two
percent a year
Japan's a wealthy country so part of the
economic growth that I think you're
talking about it we're talking about is
financial services and things that
aren't hard goods right where we only
used to count hard goods washing
machines cars and so on
now we're counting economic growth is
you know you know other things that
aren't necessarily hard goods but I'm
not dodging your question but I think
it's clear that despite increasing
population in the United States and
despite increasing wealth we've seen
energy demand flatline so the short
answer is I think at a certain level of
wealth Jevons is wrong but that that is
only true for a relatively small
percentage of the world population and
we're among them we have time for one
more question question up here or right
here all right so I understand that we
will export and use the cheapest energy
possible but do you believe that we will
not innovate to make a practical source
of green energy and/or if you do do you
believe that the subsidies that are in
place now are inhibiting the advancement
of green energy of a practical greener
energy resource let me address the last
part because I don't think the subsidies
are inhibiting the growth in fact the
subsidies subsidies have been critical
to the growth if you look between 2012
when the wind industry had the
production tax credit and 2013 when the
tax credit was not in existence new
installations of wind turbines fell 92%
so subsidies have driven and mandates
have driven renewable policy and
renewable installations
but let me just address a different part
of your question because you talked
about innovation I've talked primarily
about production and innovation in
production we've seen marvelous
innovation in the shale revolution here
in the United States with drillers
drilling faster wells or drilling them
cheaper producing more but the flip side
of that goes back to the the other
gentleman's question about efficiency
and at the same time we've increased the
efficiency of our production we're
increasing the efficiency of our
conversion so that we're making more
efficient lights we're making more
efficient cars I'm a big fan of Alan
Mulally at Ford what was his signature
achievement at Ford I would argue it's
the 1 liter EcoBoost engine it's a 1
liter 3-cylinder turbocharged engine
that produces 123 horsepower 3 cylinder
1 liter turbo engine that produces 123
horsepower the power density in that
engines 92 thousand watts per liter the
power density is roughly the same as
that in the Bugatti Veyron a supercar
that cost 1.2 million dollars and here
for it is selling that engine by the
hundreds of thousands and it's
incredibly efficient so this efficiency
is yes we can talk about renewables and
you know the need to produce more but at
the same time which and it is in which
is incredibly exciting is where we're
getting more and more effective at
turning energy into useful power of all
kinds lighting power computing power
motive power this is where the gold is
and this is why I'm so bullish on the
future and particularly bullish on the
United States because we're innovating
in those areas at a pace that the rest
of the world isn't matching okay I think
I've got the hook here thank you very
much
come down here